kovat is very serious we're taking it
seriously
obviously it's having an impact like it
is everywhere else in the nation and it
doesn't mean that we're not prepared and
we're not working actively like most
Americans are to mitigate this thing on
March 30th The Washington Post reported
that according to anonymous defense
officials between twenty and fifty
positive cases have been confirmed at
the Marine Corps Recruit Depot in Parris
Island South Carolina where about 20,000
marine recruits graduate from a 13 week
training program every year we did have
a increase in Kovac cases among the
recruit population based on that we had
everyone there in contact with already
in quarantine so they were quarantined
immediately with the number of confirmed
cases rising the Pentagon ordered
individual military bases to stop
providing specific numbers of kovat 19
cases to the press and public out of a
concern for operational security with
regard to readiness we spoke on the
phone with recruit depot spokesperson
Captain Brian McDonald about how the
kovat 19 crisis is impacting recruits
during training Cove it is very serious
we're taking it seriously as if the rest
of the deity's but it's one element an
uncertainty in a world that has more
factors than aperture which is why the
Marine Corps exists the footage of
training in this video was shot when we
visited Parris Island in October of 2019
when new recruits arrived at Parris
Island they normally step onto these
yellow footprints which symbolizes the
beginning of their training now amid the
crisis all incoming recruits undergo a
14 day staging period before they set
foot on the yellow footprints
during staging they are medically
screened multiple times a day regardless
of whether someone is symptomatic or not
when they arrive on the depot they'll be
in a holding pattern for two weeks until
they come out clear on the other side of
that but new route
fruits won't be arriving at Parris
Island for at least a week as of March
30th the shipment of new recruits is
temporarily suspended according to the
recruit depot new physical distancing
measures are being implemented like in
the squad base where recruits sleep
there must now be 6 feet in between each
rack or bed recruits also practice
physical distancing in the chow hall
where more space is being opened up and
utilized for recruits to safely eat
their meals but training will go on and
as you can see from these pictures taken
on March 24th some exercises require
close physical contact like martial arts
according to MacDonald physical distance
II is being implemented in training at
the discretion of the instructors there
are folks in various stages of training
that have been here for weeks
it's been assessed based on medical
input and various other factors that
their overall risk of kovat exposure is
quite low relative to folks who are
coming out of the depot but people also
need to be trained how to fight how to
shoot how to swim to do all those things
that that we do as ranges
graduations like this one will continue
to occur but they're closed to all
visitors according to MacDonald physical
distancing will be implemented into
marching formations with space between
each graduate following graduation the
new Marines will ship out of Parris
Island and head to the training that
subsequently occurs on other bases
companies currently on the depot right
now the plan is that they will continue
to train in a modified and responsible
way COBIT is one uncertain factor in the
world full of uncertainties which is why
we have a marine core so it's definitely
important to us that we take care of our
recruits certainly not easy but I would
attest that it's not easy for most folks
around America trying to figure out how
to grapple with this
[Music]